everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm and today we are in round
seven of our coverage of the twenty20
Canada's tournament winner of this
tournament has gone to face Magnus
Carlsen the world championships later
this year our competitors today in round
seven just happened to be the top two
players at the top of the leaderboard in
second place coming into this game is
mvl he is playing the white pieces
remember he's only in this tournament
because someone dropped out he's been
trying to play in the Canada's
tournament for some time now finally got
his chance trying to prove himself in
this tournament he is one full point
behind jana Pullman of chi and he's
playing the black pieces having an
outstanding tournament playing the black
pieces in at this tournament so I'll go
and get started with NBL starts out with
E 4 and then e 6 you hate to see it the
French defense just something when I
play E for a lot always hate running
into the French defense d4 d5 getting
into the main line after Knight to c3
Bishop down to before this is the one
over variation we did chess opening a
video on this so if you haven't seen a
few not familiar with the French defense
definitely go check that video out I'll
have the link below just so if you want
to do some prep work as far as this
opening you can do that but play
continues with E 5 pawn down here to c5
and then after a3 forcing the bishop to
go somewhere decide to go ahead and take
the material pawn recaptures right here
so white does have double pawns on the C
foul not as bad when it's towards the
center of the board and it's connected
it'd be much worse if this pawn was not
here but this does open up for a
semi-open file for the rook to come here
to be won at some point control this
open B file you can usually tell where
the attacks gonna be where the pawns are
pointed so you can see that these pawns
right here are aimed at this King side
of the board so putting a lot of
pressure look to be attacking on the
King side and limit some of the squares
this pawn here on e5 the knight can't
come to his natural square of Knight to
f6 that's going to be coming to e7 which
is exactly where it comes black is
really going to be looking to overwhelm
on the Queen side of the board White's
gonna be looking to attack on the King
side of the board now a fairly novel
move from nvl and he starts out with h4
I usually see in this variation Queen to
g4 attacking this pawn here on g7 or
just getting the knight here to f3 both
of those seem logical to me he plays h4
and then Queen to c7 which is the
natural way to attack this and then we
see h5 continue to push on the Kings
side and I'm not sure what was more
surprising as I saw this the move h5 or
h6 the main reason that you play Queen
to c7 is that if they play something
like h5 then you can take with your pawn
here on d4 and then after they take you
can come down and check right here
Queen to c3 check they play Bishop to d2
makes a lot of sense and then you can
take right here
maybe Knight to f3 Queen to e4 those all
seem pretty logical to me maybe Bishop
to e2 Knight to f5 Black has a pretty
good position here but instead we see
just h6 so I think instead of a chive if
he wanted to play Knight to f3 I mean I
know there's a lot of preparation that
went into this but usually I would
expect to see after the Queen to c7
something like Knight to f3 but he's
going all-in h5 and then we see Yan
trying to stop that with h6 rook to be
one attack in the semi open file as we
talked about before
b6 just solidifying the Queen side a
pawn chain here Queen to G Force now
starting to attack that King side of the
board rook the g8 defending that Bishop
to b5 check trying to get as much
material involved into the action as
possible King comes over here to f8
couldn't castle anyway the rook had
already moved so don't have to worry too
much wants to protect the King side has
both his rookie and his king defending
it right now Bishop comes back to d3 and
then Bishop dae-sik says yeah we
we can exchange material if you want to
first we have some pawns come off the
board and then after the pawns recapture
here
you can see that white no longer has the
double pawns now he has a backward pawn
here on c3 that you may have to worry
about at some point but he has been able
to get rid of the double pawns here on
the C file now both sides they have the
open B file so at some point you're
gonna expect to see a rook come here to
b8 you don't want your opponent to just
openly control that B file here first we
see the Queen come back here to a d1
just preparing to swing over to the
Queen side of the board Queen to a5
attacking both the backward pawn here on
a c3 which is very open right now
white definitely needs to defend that as
the King would be exposed to that as
well and also wants to attack this pawn
here on a3 so a lot of threats that
black has we see the bishop come here to
d2 stopping this immediate threat here
on c3 rook to b8 Knight up here to f2
now we could have if we wanted to see
the Queen take on a3 but then Knight to
e2 don't know that it really matters too
much for black I thought he may have
decided to take that pawn but in the
game decided to just bring his rook over
here to b8 now Knight to e2 as we talked
about pawn to c4 so really pushing you
can see where these pawns are are
pointing they are pointed towards the
Queen side are the board and so that's
where blacks gonna be looking to attack
as we already mentioned White's gonna be
looking to attack on the King side of
the board we do see white castle so
getting his King and safety here it's
gonna be a while before yon can actually
attack the white king rook to a b6 just
says yeah if White's gonna take my
material here I don't want to be
exchanging and bringing my knight back
here to to be 8 so now rook to b6 if
there ever is in exchange
now the knight can take here the pond
can take care if he wants to even the
Queen can take but it's in a much better
position
back here on a v8 so after rook to b6 we
see Queen to c2 just wants to be a
little more centralized still
maintaining some presence on the Queen
side the board still protecting this
pawn here on c3 as well as the bishop
and the knight but then also allows the
rook or the Queen to swing over here to
something like h7 if there ever is a
potential threat to pose on the
opponent's rook dayj does not want to
even worry about the Queen coming over
here to h7 and then we see Queen or pawn
to a4 still protected by the Queen so we
can start to push up a little bit on the
board King to e8 rook to b4 and then
Knight to c6 attacking the rook here on
b4 and here's where things get pretty
interesting it really felt like we were
going to see this rook maybe exchange
material here on the Queen side of the
board or just come back and say yeah we
will fight another day here NBL says
you're attacking my rook
don't care pawn to f4 Oh baby it is time
to start the attack on the King side
says I don't care if you take this
material and you don't seem to be taken
aback by this because he didn't even
take this material which I think he
absolutely could have Knight takes here
pawn recaptures attacking the Queen
maybe Queen back here to a6 pawned b5
and the Queen swings back Bishop to a5
attacking the rook although honestly as
I was looking at it and I think b5 makes
a lot of sense you could just see full
Yolo with f5 and just throw everything
at the King side and say I'm not even
gonna attack of the Queen just do what
you want don't really know what would
have happened if we saw the knight take
here on b4 but in the game we see the
knight come back here to e7 so it seems
like yawns looking at the board and
since is a big threat coming from NBL so
wants to stop any sort of shenanigans
with f5 so not worried about the rook
too much right now more word
about the kingside the board Brooke
swings over to a b1 says yeah if you
want to take my rook I'm gonna have some
protection right there and then f5 so
making sure that the pawn can't push up
any further we do see rook to b5
attacking the Queen Queen comes back
here to a6 Bishop to c1 recognising hey
bishops not doing too much let's go
ahead and maneuver it over here to the
a3 squares to start to attack my
opponent here King to f7 Bishop a3 work
over here to b8 and then the bishop
takes on e7 now at the beginning of the
game you're usually not gonna see
bishops trading off with Knights you you
like to hold on to your bishops an open
game meaning there's not a lot of pawns
in the center of the board
once the pawns comes off the board or
once the pawns are off the board bishops
are better but once they're just
clogging up the center bishops don't do
as well and so really good observation
by nvl2 maneuvers bishop recognizing
it's not doing too much but this night
on e7 is maneuvering over the board and
controlling a lot of what White's trying
to do somebody else says yeah I'm gonna
go ahead and trade off my piece that's
not doing too much for your piece that
is extremely active King recaptures on
e7 and then we start to see the push
here with g4 rook takes here on b5 so we
finally see the exchange now we do see
the pawn on b5 have an option as far as
how he wanted to retake but decide to
take with this pawn here rook takes pawn
takes here on f5 rook takes down here on
b1 Queen comes back and recaptures and
then the pawns take so interesting
dynamic that we have here black has six
bonds
White has five pawns both sides have a
passed pawn right here we have the pawn
here on e5 is a passed pawn as well as
this pawn here on a7 but White has a
pretty good setup he also has a fairly
safe King right here on a g1 and there's
some backward pawns that white can
easily start to attack so it's gonna be
interesting getting into the in game
although black is up material almost
like White's position
a little bit more first we see Knight to
g3 attacking the pawn here on f5
probably better to do this than just
taking up here with Queen takes on f 5
then Queen over here to e6 I just don't
like this position as much when we see
Knight to g3 attacking the pawn if the
Queen were to come over here right now
that I can still take here it's
protected by this Queen here on b1 so
Knight to g3 pretty safe to get the
material back and even the material for
both sides of the board Queen to b6
attacking the Queen right here but can
still freely take exactly as he does
here on f5 check King comes back here to
FA don't want to try anything obviously
can't come to d6 or f6 because the pawns
but you can't just come to e6 because
then you're gonna see Knight to g7 check
and then maybe the King comes back and
then the Queen swings up here to h7 it's
just all sort of just bad news for for
black so if we come back a few moves in
the game after the knight comes up here
to f5 then we see the King come back
here to f8 now Queen 2 a1 Queen over
here to e6 Knight comes back to g3
and then queen g4 now this is pinning
down the Knights but after the King
comes to g2 just doesn't have a lot of
threats on the board yes he can take
this material right here but after that
how does he really continue where White
has some pretty strong attacks so after
Queen takes on f4 which is exactly what
happened in the game Queen takes on a7
and all of a sudden White has the only
passed pawn and he's gonna start to push
that on the board and that is a major
advantage especially getting into the
endgame and you have your Queen back
here that can help support that
so King to e7 protecting the night here
on a d7 Queen to a3 check King comes
back here d8 and then Queen to d6 the
final nail in the coffin there's no way
for black to really come back from this
the Knights being pinned down
pushing forward here to e6 gonna be the
next move there's no way to stop that
yan tries starting with g5 but then we
see on pissant capturing now White has
to pass pawns h5 and then after g7
realizes ok this is this is all bad news
there's just no way to stop this so at
the end of it
yan decides to resign and in DL gets the
victory and now is tied coming into the
game leaving a full point and got
exactly that y'all looking for the drawl
and win for the French defense which
generally speaking is a pretty drawing
but white navigated very well and ended
up with the victory so we have two
players tied at the top now and it's the
ones we do looked at NBL as well as
young so hope you guys enjoy this video
I always like to watch a good efore
opening take down the French defense but
hopefully you guys have enjoyed round 7
we are halfway through the tournament so
there's a lot of chess to be played but
I appreciate you guys tuning in to all
the videos and we will be back tomorrow
for round number 8